donc nader des sujets il conserve ce
violente au maître alors franchement en
lisant l'article de la lettre à
on pouvait croire à une blague mais
pourtant c'est bien vrai l'info c'est
celle ci valérie pécresse lance violente
est violente au m pour évaluer les élus
de la région ile-de-france qu'elle
préside
alors ils vont être classés ainsi vers
dans la zone sérénité pour ceux qui
écoutent courtoisement leurs collègues
orange c'est la zone vigilance pour ce
qui va pas tout téléphone dans
l'hémicycle et rouge alors là attention
c'est la zone protection pour ceux qui
agressent ou blessent un de leur
collègue sophie badia c'est drôle
stupide les deux à la fois
moi j'adore le débat je fais un métier
où le débat est autorisé et parfois il
est virulent mois le débat c'est la vie
donc si l'on commence à donner des
points en fonction du silence finalement
qu'on vous qu'on est capable d'accepter
dans un débat ça m'inquiète et je trouve
ça relativement infantile en fait pour
tout silence matière ou simplement
savoir bien se comporter respecter les
règles de courtoisie élémentaire partage
votre sentiment je trouve que alors bon
après je ne connais pas la situation
peut être que valérie pécresse se
retrouve confronté alors ils m'ont
semblé particulièrement du lot mais un
élu a l'air de francs mais je vais
encore me voilà dhabi qui lui a
travaillé la question
non mais après bon il ya peut-être un
cas de figure particulier qu'il faut
régler d'une personne voilà mais la
généraliser sa paresse à caractère c'est
ridicule dit comme ça présenté comme ça
tel qu'on ne peut pas les gérer intérêts
d'abord des jeunes étaient telles que
effectivement les papiers qu'on était
c'est un côté des fois je trouve que
c'est ridicule et ça vient plus des
modèles des violences faites aux femmes
coup d'une mesure dont deux hommes deux
femmes président au pouldu the ballad
bizarre allez vous avez tout à fait
raison puisque c'est inspiré du
deux dispositifs pour calculer ou pour
réguler ou pour essayer de cadres mettre
un terme
les violences faites aux femmes sont un
peu bizarres
alors oui après les connais pas la
situation très précise aussi que bon
pour vous donner à réfléchir on va
revoir un échange qui avait pas mal le
fait parler de lui c'était à l'assemblée
entre la présidente de la commission
ad-hoc sur la loi pacte olivia grégoire
en l'espèce et françois refaire député
france insoumise on regarde alors
habitués vous venez avec des tampons y
revenez avec des boules quiès mais
laissez moi tranquille
laissez nous sermonner merci non non non
non mais je rêve
non non non alors monsieur rufin vous
allez baissé d'un ton vous avez quatre
minutes je précède la mission spéciale
on vient mature et dispose d'une voix
qui peut être largement supérieure à la
vôtre
on a quatre minutes ça s'est toujours
passé ainsi dans le respect de chacun et
comme le dit monsieur de courson
personne né sourd mais laissez moi ça je
ne vois pas cela mais pour terminer mon
propos madame je vous remercie
elle illustre cet extrait ça ne vient
pas de plus en plus compliqué de mener
un débat vient du théâtre pas cessé il
ya beaucoup de théâtralité là surtout
que je stresse ils posaient ensemble
avec des mots qui est embêtant mais s'il
se plaît à ce moment là elle fait acte
d'autorité c'est la police de l'audience
est d'ailleurs un moment donné on ne
peut plus parler puis on peut parler à
nouveau
ceci étant vous médias de le dire j'ai
ainsi qu'un d'énergie mais pas vraiment
dans l'instant françois répit les
changes chez gft récemment un débat
judiciaire ou la partie adverse mettait
des boules quiès et là je me suis
inquiété effectivement ai dit qu'est ce
que c'est il ya plus de débat
je ne peux pas entendre sans réagir
pourtant il faut l'accepter le débat 6 à
préciser nan mais un petit peu je vais
défendre le v l'endomètre ou des enfants
car non mais je suis pas beaucoup
merci je le la philosophie de ce fantôme
être c'est que dans des conseils
municipaux dans des enceintes
départementales ou régionales très
clairement
parfois parce qu'à une passion il ya des
élus n'ont pas sûr non pas sur les
discussions n'ont pas sur le fond mais
son qui met sur la forme qui pète
l'équipe est plomb qui se comporte de
manière extrêmement incorrect pour
prendre un exemple national
on se souvient des cris de poule quand
véronique massenot à l'assemblée
nationale prenez la parole des des
remarques sexistes la robe à fleurs de
cécile duflot on en parlait tout eu
toute une série de choses alors il ya un
règlement à l'assemblée nationale qui
est stricte on ne sait pas je connais
pas le
laure et le règlement en ile de france
mais c'est vrai qu'il m'arrive dates à
venir devant des conseils municipaux ou
céreq parfois il ya un niveau glace je
parle pas du fond des discussions d'un
président d'une présidente qui
d'autorité coupe la parole coupent les
micros c'est ça qui crée beaucoup de
tensions notamment à l'assemblée la
semaine mais de ce type de comportement
alors je n'ai pas tout à fait saisi la
nature de l'incident entre jérôme
chartier et monsieur serve mais
peut-être que ça a été particulièrement
tendue
je suis peut-être commis quand on lit un
petit peu il or le règlement tel qu'il
est prévu vers les bâtiments sentait bon
le vert d'accord mais moi ce que je
trouve un peu facile en fait de la zone
vigilance dite orange puisque je trouve
ça bizarre
si vous êtes en train de regarder votre
téléphone de tout téléphone ou
téléphoner c'est pas pour toi je
l'admets totalement mais je ne vois pas
le rapport avec le fait d'abord
d'adopter un comportement de harcèlement
sexuel ça c'est pas du tout la même
nature verte et aux paroles pour ce
n'est pas le retour
enfin bon bref c'est vraiment peut-on
mettre sur au même niveau à harcèlement
sexuel et le fait de prendre la parole
avant quelqu'un d'autre sauf si l'on
considère que c'est du harcèlement
sexuel ce qui est un parti qui peut
arriver mais c'est un peu complexe
donc je trouve que c'est un peu bizarre
donc excessif qu'on en vient aux mains
ou qu'il ya des injures le droit pénal
vient régir tout ça donc c'est un peu
démagogique si je puis dire on va
regarder ce qu'en pensent nos
internautes ce que je vais dire question
composé le violente au maître qui
devient célèbre destiné à évaluer les
élus franciliens est il une bonne idée
non à 62% mais quand même deux tiers/un
tiers
minouche est cet amusant mais dans le
fond elle a raison lorsque vous entendez
un téléphone sonne et en réunion et
voyez l'agressivité de certains brownie
tôt a quand même bêtise omettre un
démago mettre un déontologie m pour les
élus et christophe le débat politique
est une friction il est logique que le
thon puisse monter il ne faut pas
acheter la docilité avec un outil
d'évaluation un dernier mot mathieu
bobino study
j'attends la réaction de monsieur domino
lll viendra j'espère merci de le
solliciter
mais ça sera peut-être pas pour
aujourd'hui alors attention parce que la
prochaine fois peut-être les invités de
points de vue seront classées selon le
violent tôt mais je ne sais pas j'en
connais peut-être certains qui pourrait
flirter avec la zone orange je ne
donnerai pas de nom en tout cas les tous
les cas tout avait été parfait merci
beaucoup et demain vous retrouver
l'excellent et très courtois guillaume
roquette
[Musique]